premier déplacement de campagne dans les
yvelines pour valérie pécresse dans le
cadre des élections régionales dimanche
2 mai la candidate était à saint germain
les sur le marché elle est allée à la
rencontre des habitants et des
commerçants
je vais évidemment aller partout mais
c'était évidemment très important pour
moi aussi d'être dans les yvelines
parce que je vais être accompagné d'une
équipe formidable d'illinois de tous les
territoires qui ressemble aux yvelines
et je voulais vraiment venir les
mobiliser dès ce matin sur place elle a
détaillé les mesures de son programme
valérie pécresse compte mettre en place
un rer vélo aussi une aide de 6000 euros
sera proposé pour l'achat d'un véhicule
électrique en vue de la future zone de
faible émission à l'intérieur de l'a86
la candidate met aussi l'accent sur la
santé
nous allons faire une mutuelle régional
pour baisser les tarifs des mutuelles
notamment pour ceux qui n'ont pas de
mutuelle employeur et nous allons faire
aussi une garantie immobilière solidaire
pour aider tous ceux qui ont été malades
qui ont eu un cancer qui ont lieu qui
ont le vih la mucoviscidose de pouvoir
annuler leur surprime d'assurance pour
qu'ils puissent devenir propriétaire en
ile de france
enfin la candidate souhaite mettre un
bouclier tarifaires sur les longues
distances en transport si elle est élue
aucun de ces tickets ne devrait être
supérieur à 4 euros
pendant son déplacement elle était
accompagnée des sénateurs et du maire de
saint germain en laye en soutien à la
candidate c'est une candidate de
conviction c'est une candidate de
prouver surtout et qui projette notre
territoire francilien bien au delà
voilà des quelques mois qui viennent et
c'est une candidate qui je crois à des
valeurs et à saint germain on est une
ville de valeur et c'est important pour
nous invité sur lci le soir de ses
déplacements elle a confirmé qu'elle
n'envisageait aucune alliance politique
ni au premier ni au second tour